[Music]
vietnamese food is bountiful in portland
from pho to bon me it's hard to miss
but among your classic vietnamese
restaurants there is one tiny place
that makes soups from different regions
of vietnam that you can't find anywhere
else outside the country
how that place came to be involves the
cia and is one hell of a journey you
know
it's a long story
[Music]
my name is william
i'm from south vietnam
i am the owner with my wife
the rovio
restaurant in portland
i started working with the cac 1962
i do many things you know
i know the interpreter translator and
then i become like an intelligent leader
by the time the us pulled out of the
vietnam war in 1973 william was put in
jail by the communist regime he would
spend the next 10 years of his life in
prison the communist government
confiscated my house
the car and money in the bank
every day we do very very
heavy labor work and many people get
killed
after being released it took williams
six years to reunite with his family who
settled in portland
[Music]
away from his homeland and missing the
comforts of home cooking he had an idea
in a normal restaurant they make the big
pan of broad
and they use that product to do many
different dishes but here we make very
very sharp from each soap only six days
a week william and his wife christina
come in and make two distinct soups from
scratch each soup representing a
different part of vietnam
that's it
a two item menu that changes daily and
by early afternoon
they sell out nice and my wife come here
5 45 every morning starting cooking and
prepare for the food for the soup for
the broth
my wife takes care of the cooking
dispenser for
fit noodle
5 am wake up 6 days a week complex broth
from scratch
people half their age wouldn't be able
to last long
so how are they still going
because my wife loves cooking i want to
retire
[Music]
you